what's up brother am i on
yeah you're on okay great yeah i was
having an
error with this but uh so right now i am
in a ltr and i know you you hate that
but i was thinking okay i'm you're the
young right you're like 22
23 24 24 24 okay
yeah so 24 in an ltr
and i'm just like whenever i go to the
gym it's just like
um there could be so many other options
and it's kind of hard because i'm
especially in my 20s i'm like oh wow
there's
attracting girls and i'm doing very well
for myself at my age so i'm like
okay how can i somehow keep the value of
the ltr
and still uh explore other options
so somehow in a roundabout way i
convinced
my ltr to be open to threesomes so is
that what is that
that's a pretty cool balance in terms of
getting what i want and still keeping an
ltr
hey listen dude have you ever had a
threesome i i'm not
okay well what are you waiting for like
get it on come back and report man
make sure it's two chicks and you know
yeah not like you know
she brings some dude into the picture
you don't want to be crossing swords and
doing some
some weird stuff you know i'm saying hey
we can't have two blondes that's like
the only rule
it'll be competing blondes oh is that
the ruler she said you can't have two
blondes in the
as long as she's not blonde okay so
is your girlfriend bi or is she like
just open to
exploring with you she's just very
competitive with other blondes
i suppose uh this doesn't answer the
question though like is she buying
no she's not bi i don't believe so now
you don't believe so she ever had an
experience with another woman before
i wouldn't be surprised if she kissed
another girl but not like scissoring
anything like that uh you know just you
know women typically don't scissor when
you have threesomes just
heads up like fyi
you would watch a little too much porn
there bro um
the um okay so
she's never had a threesome then right
to my knowledge no okay you probably
want to ask that question because if
she's open to having a threesome she's
either going to be bi
or she's attracted women or she's
bi-curious or she's done it before you
just want to make sure that she hasn't
had a train runner by a bunch of guys is
all i'm saying here right you know
before you hop into this
now how are you going to go about
selecting this check
uh it's going to come very quickly dark
hair brown hair
okay okay but how are you going to bring
her into the mix
so i have really good success at uh
talking to girls at the gym
it's kind of like my only free place
and i think that is a great place to
start in terms of it's not going to be
like oh you won't have a threesome like
right off the bat it's kind of like
did she go to the gym with you uh no she
doesn't good
you don't want women to work out with
the bottom line so here so here's the
better way to do it you're going to get
her to download an app like
bumble or tinder i think bumble's
probably going to be better for
something like this she's going to do
you know women seeking women okay okay
yeah and then you have her find the girl
right because if you're going to go and
find her and bring her in she's going to
try to compete with her right
i mean she's already setting the
boundary of oh you know you can't have
two blondes in the same room sort of
thing because it's going to be me and
her
have her find the girl and then you have
to go and approve her when she's kind of
narrowed it down because
she's probably going to find a chick
that's going to be grosser than her
women don't well it's because women
don't want to be in a situation where
you know the other girl's prettier
she's got a nicer body or something like
that so you're going to have to whittle
it down to something that's acceptable
but that's usually the best way to go
about doing it okay
yeah i i like that put it in her hands
to find it
right you make her do the work and then
you just go and you know make the final
approval
and then just you know grab a drink
shoot the [ __ ] you know get a little
flirty and then you just
invite him over jack shalak give it away
done right yeah you can go tell all your
buddies and you can say hey you know
this guy rich coop helped me out by the
way guys if you want to make a donation
my bitcoin address is always in the
description
i i like crypto it's all good oh you
know what this
do you is what this logo is right here e
with the horns no what is that
oh it's a it's a crypto uh company
and which one they give you it's called
etoro
okay i haven't heard of it yeah it's
pretty unique real quick
uh so basically you put money uh with
different investors and they pretty much
like invest for you in bitcoin they
trade for you and
you can set your stop losses it's kind
of unique
you never own your keys though right
this is kind of like one of these
platforms where they run it for you
yeah you can select your they call it
copy traders
but you want to select your uh copy
trader and they'll buy
and sell whatever so business is good
for you
uh well my career i mean in terms of my
job
excellent i would say uh making moves
i'm doing great in that front
in terms of starting something of my own
it is becoming sparingly as work is like
taking more and more time
so it's going to be a slow process over
time but i
i see myself being where i am right now
for at least four more years
uh in terms of my position good so
um there's a uh cautionary note here
from tuscany says be careful you might
lose your ltr that's that's why
i i said let her pick the girls yeah and
then you little down from there
i'm actually not too nervous about
losing her like if she goes she goes
like
well you have to be okay with a girl
leaving at any given time right you just
have to understand that all women
can be replaced let me ask you this
question so you can give the audience a
little bit of advice
um how did you approach or pose the
question to her when you were like let's
have a threesome or did she bring it up
oh uh well quite frankly she wanted to
take the relationship to the next step
right what's the next step interview
she's like oh when are you gonna propose
to me all my friends are
all your friends are proposing and i was
like
i was like um i'm you know i'm my 20s i
was just pretty straight up with her i'm
in my 20s
there's a lot of things i haven't
explored yet like for example
a threesome and then very very like
uh rejecting at first and then i was
like well i mean at least once and then
kind of like okay at least once
and it kind of works out that way but i
mean at the end of the day whatever i
say whatever i want
from her she will provide it to me and
it's not so much as and i'm demanding of
her
it's kind of like if you want to like
making me happy makes her happy
so um yeah she's totally in your frame
so that's good
um by the way after she's started to
narrow down the girls
uh tell her to put the girl or the girls
it's probably just gonna be one but
put him in like a group chat either on
signal telegram whatsapp whatever so
that all three of you are in the chat so
you can kind of communicate together so
there's nothing being missed
and then that way you can kind of move
it closer towards you know
closing on that deal with the threesome
come back and let me know how you make
out with that you know when you go
through with it
okay yeah that's good
having her download bumble all right man
get to work
all right see bro peace
you